we
see the poster with johnny cage he says
i'm heading to hollywood
did that come from you was he was cage
always the character we were gonna tease
what does that mean for the future of
this franchise
so uh so no so uh
so so basically the idea is like movie
one we were always kind of setting this
up as
well i was setting it up i don't know
it's basically in my head
i always saw it as pre-tournament right
pre-tournament
then hopefully tournament the post
tournament so the idea was like this was
going to be a pre-tournament
movie that was that would hopefully sow
the seeds for
the tournament the fight from from the
beginning you kind of conceived this is
a trilogy for chapter one
yeah interesting a writer you you you
and this is by the way this was this was
um
the the overall everybody was focused on
movie one you don't get a trilogy
without it so
uh but as a writer you should always you
should never be paying yourself in the
corner that's my money you should always
be thinking about where can your story
go even beyond the two hours that i
that you know this is not a lot of time
so two hours i have to tell this story
where else can it go
so i was kind of i saw it as kind of
leading up to uh something bigger
and um and so the idea then became all
right we're gonna have you know we have
certain amount of characters we can fit
um
you know don't have the luxury of having
uh individual
movies of all these characters uh i'm
gonna get thrown right into avengers
mode which is uh
fun and a challenge um but you know i
knew that there were other characters i
just
i couldn't get in and and that actually
didn't even make sense to bring in yet
for the story so
yeah then it became a matter of uh well
who's the big characters that we want to
save you know because you also don't
want to
you know you don't want to use
everything you know uh and so
yeah johnny johnny's tease at the end
the button
it changed different ways i remember
there were different versions of it
um you know that poster was something
that the design team
did uh which i love i love i picked them
i picked citizen cage because i just
loved
i thought that was fight for your rights
so i picked i picked that
and put in the script and then they
designed that amazing poster
and then it had lived at other places so
it actually wasn't the button
for a while earlier in the story like
they were walking and you just see it in
the background
and we felt like uh that just wasn't
enough i think it just felt like it
wasn't enough so you wanted to you
wanted to really hit on it
and i remember there was a version for
the end
uh where they would they actually went
to like the lot
so cole and the other sonia and went to
like the studio lot
and they i forget what it even was they
like pulled up and they were and it was
like they were going
right it was going to be shot at warner
brothers right they were going to the
meeting and
but it just felt like with the pandemic
and everything it just got to it it was
hard to do a lot of that so
i think um i love the way that it kind
of buttons and it's simple and yeah
hopefully
we can tell more of those stories
absolutely was there ever a moment
did it get far enough into
pre-production or production where
johnny cage was cast actually no no no
gotcha never cast no that's that's i
guess that's probably why you see him
from the waist down
good point good point filmmaking trick
yeah